bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france quel est l'état des
relations entre l'espagne et le maroc
aujourd'hui ces relations sont très
bonnes en tout cas jusqu'à la semaine
dernière et je pense qu'elles
reviendront très rapidement pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il ya un socle
économique très solide
l'espagne est le premier client est le
premier fournisseur du maroc derrière
devant devant la france devant
l'allemagne et les relations bilatérales
sont assez équilibrés sur le plan
commercial et à une assez bonne
complémentarité et puis parce que les
entreprises espagnoles investissent au
maroc notamment dans le secteur des
services du tourisme dans le domaine des
infrastructures des transports notamment
et que environ 800 entreprises
espagnoles sont implantées au maroc
la deuxième raison c'est que depuis
l'attentât d'atocha à madrid
le maroc se prête à une très forte
coopération avec l'espagne dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
et puis cette coopération a été étendu à
la lutte contre les trafics de drogue
contre aussi les trafics d'êtres humains
et au final est finalement depuis aussi
plusieurs années
la france est la part dont l'espagne et
le maroc quimper pour limiter les
migrants et les trafics de l'étoile et
les migrants qui arrive quelquefois du
sahel et qui passe par les canaries ou
par ses états à midi là et avec l'aide
de frontex
les marocains et les espagnols s'efforce
de limiter ou d'empêcher ces courants de
migration illégale
il ya donc une coopération très
diversifié à telle enseigne que les
ministres de l'intérieur se voit presque
tous les mois se parle tout le temps sur
tous ces sujets et que le roi d'espagne
a fait une visite d'état il ya deux ans
qui sait
terminer quelle que ce qui s'est traduit
quelques semaines plus tard par la
conclusion d'un traité de partenariat
qualifié de multi dimensionnelle puisque
comme je voulais dit il s'adresse à la
fois à l'économie ils s'appliquent à la
lutte contre le terrorisme est également
contre l'immigration clandestine
alors cette affaire brahim ghali est-ce
qu'elle va entacher justement les
relations entre les deux royaumes et
vous laisser le gouvernement algérien
qui a demandé aux espagnols de de
prendre le chef du polisario puisque les
algériens ne parvenait plus à traiter
sont que vides 19 apparemment très grave
ils ont d'abord demandé à l'allemagne
puisque le président algérien a été
traité dans un hôpital allemand les
allemands ont plutôt décliner et par
conséquent pour des raisons humanitaires
je crois en effet l'espagne a accepté de
prendre seul le chef du polisario pour
le traité dans un hôpital près de
saragosse
ça peut permettre aussi peut-être
d'avoir des conversations avec lui et
peut-être aussi de voir dans quelle
mesure il est possible d'avoir des
négociations ultérieures avec le
polisario
donc je pense que la crise avec le maroc
est provisoire et les pour quelques
périodes mais d'ici quelques semaines le
chef du polisario va retourner en
algérie où il vit avec son avec son
gouvernement l'exil dans là où sont les
exilés sahraouis dans le camps de
tindouf et que et bien les bonnes
relations reprendront par la suite ce
qui est une solution
in fine est justement à cette question
du sahara occidental
goûtez le rapport de forces est modifié
il s'est modifié parce que le maroc a
connu une croissance économique
importante que le maroc est devenu un
acteur économique important que il joue
le rôle un peu d'intermédiaire entre
l'espagne et l'afrique que l'espagne à
réintégrer l'union africaine qui elle
avait quitté lorsque les sahraouis
avaient été admis un certain nombre
d'années par conséquent on voit bien que
le rapport de force s'est modifié et
puis le précédent président des états
unis a fait une déclaration importante
qui a un petit peu à l'armée le
secrétaire général des nations unies
lorsqu'il a dit à la fin de l'année
dernière que le sahara occidental
appartenait évidemment au maroc
alors il l'a fait dans un contexte un
peu particulier c'était pour achever
leur achève le le rapprochement entre le
maroc et israël
d'ailleurs on constate que dans les
combats qui ont eu lieu il ya peu de
temps au début de ce mois comme vous a
été mentionné dans votre reportage est
bien le maroc a utilisé des drones
d'origine israélienne
par conséquent le rapport de force s'est
modifié et aujourd'hui le problème est
plutôt pour l'espagne de convaincre le
convaincre les sahraouis et le convoque
peut-être les algériens aussi d'accepter
une solution négociée qui serait sans
doute une autonomie du sahara occidental
dans un cadre marocain sous la
souveraineté marocaine
merci beaucoup à vous claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales